this video is sponsored by morning brew
the daily newsletter about business and
tech on february 24th russia invaded
ukraine starting a war that as of the
time of recording still rages on causing
needless suffering to civilians and
personnel all in an attempt to satisfy
the ego of wannabe sar and canadian
specialty dish vladimir putin in
response to this western nations
including the uk eu and us announced a
raft of sanctions designed to collapse
the russian economy many of these
sanctions focused on russian exports of
oil and natural gas which are key to the
russian economy such as for example
cancelling the nordstrom 2 pipeline and
the eu announcing that it was phasing
out all imports of russian natural gas
this represents a problem for europe
however because natural gas ultimately
accounts for 22 of all of the energy
used in europe and russia supplies 40
of it and that energy's got to come from
somewhere but this is also an
opportunity
contrary to what the industry wants you
to believe natural gas is not a clean
fuel it emits approximately 490 tons of
co2 for each gigawatt hour of power
supplied making it cleaner than coal but
british footies grand compared to the
hawk cuisine of renewables such as wind
and solar as long as natural gas is in
the european energy mix not only are we
emitting a lot of co2 into the
atmosphere we're also partly dependent
on russia with all of the associated
questions that comes with that about
energy security in this video i'm going
to talk about how europe specifically
should and indeed currently says it will
remove its dependence on natural gas
though all these talking points really
apply to any economy wanting to degas
its energy mix firstly consider where
europe uses its energy approximately
fifty percent of all energy is
ultimately used for heating or cooling
thirty percent for transport and twenty
percent for electricity forty two 42 of
heating is supplied by natural gas and
18 of electricity with transport having
a negligible contribution by natural gas
though it should be noted all of these
statistics are european averages and
vary wildly country by country so to
remove dependence on natural gas and
also reduce carbon emissions the number
one priority is finding an alternative
source of energy for heating with
electricity generation actually being a
distant second and it's worth stressing
that if the specific goal here is to
remove dependence on russian natural gas
then we don't need to entirely remove
gas from the energy mix we just need to
reduce its use by about 40 percent or so
anything above that is an ecological
bonus heating itself can be broken down
into heating buildings heating as part
of industry heating water for domestic
use and other miscellaneous uses of
heating heating as part of industry also
known as process heating is pretty
varied but often specialized that
offered by burning natural gas so let's
assume we can't work with that for now
heating and cooling buildings on the
other hand the largest chunk of the pie
is absolutely an area that can reduce
its use of natural gas the easiest way
to do this is simply to improve the
efficiency of heating a house meaning
improving roof insulation wall
insulation window insulation you name it
doing so means that you don't need to
use as much energy to heat homes meaning
you don't need to use as much fuel
simple proven technology that can be
widely rolled out rapidly
nice however you can also change how
homes and their water are heated and
this isn't some sci-fi idea i'm talking
about a proven technology that has been
rolled out in over 23 million homes in
the eu alone
instead of using a gas boiler use an
electric heat pump these heat pumps come
in a variety of flavors transferring
energy from either air or water or
ground but they all basically work like
fridges in reverse using electricity to
keep a volume of air at a certain
temperature this is technology that's
been shown to work in a wide range of
settings including even very cold
countries and producing only a fraction
of the co2 emissions of a gas boiler the
downside
they are more expensive than gas boilers
what european governments could do to
transition the heating sector away from
the use of natural gas is provide
financial support to people who want to
better insulate their homes or replace
their gas boiler with an electric heat
pump that sounds like it would be a very
expensive thing to do but one high level
scheme would beg to differ the italian
super bonus scheme designed to upgrade
the country's largely outdated heating
systems pays a homeowner 110
of the cost of eco-friendly alterations
to their house yes you heard me right
110
so they cover the cost of the work and
then provide a bonus but here's the
amazing thing while the scheme has been
dogged by corruption and the inevitable
inflation of the cost of work and had a
huge initial outlay
it actually made the italian government
money analysis suggests that the scheme
increased italy's gdp by 0.7
and created 153 000 new jobs in low
carbon home construction and renovation
the eu estimates that three quarters of
all the dwellings in it are energy
inefficient meaning this is a colossal
opportunity ambitious schemes in low
carbon heating like the super bonus all
over europe could reduce dependence on
natural gas modernize the workforce and
provide a post-covert economic boost
while there's always the possibility of
mismanagement with schemes like this
looking at you northern ireland this
could very well be a triple win more
than that actually because improving the
efficiency of heating homes reduces the
running costs protecting people on low
incomes and it means they don't have to
make the horrible choice between eating
and staying warm a choice that people
are already having to make in some third
world countries like the united kingdom
altogether this seems like a no-brainer
power generation is the other area where
progress can be made europe gets about
18 of its electricity from natural gas
right now a proportion that could
absolutely be replaced by simply
building further renewable generation
wind and solar in particular in fact the
ever wonderful and excellently named dr
simon evans estimates that the uk for
example already has enough wind and
solar projects with planning permission
just as yet unbuilt to make up for the
country's electricity shortfall caused
by cutting off russian gas supplies
accelerating the process of giving
permits broadening areas where projects
will be considered for example onshore
wind here in the uk and providing tax
breaks or other financial incentives to
new renewable developments would allow
natural gas to be phased out of our
electricity mix within a handful of
years again note though that i'm not
proposing to completely remove gas from
the energy mix yet at the moment it
still fulfills a useful role as a backup
to variable renewable generation and
provides inertia to the system the
objective here is just to remove at
least 40 percent of the gas generation
that which uses russian gas compared to
reforming how europeans heat their homes
this is actually pretty easy to do
you're just modifying existing
legislation and potentially chucking in
a financial incentive all absolutely
within the overton window
we should be demanding this of our
politicians oh and before anyone says it
in the comments by the way no nuclear
isn't really an option here it's just
too slow new nuclear takes about 10
years between planning construction and
commissioning construction alone takes
84 months on average a new wind project
takes less than 12 months to build and
is a lot easier to get permission for
for the task at hand nuclear is just not
the appropriate tool this war is a
tragedy and it forces a lot of hard
choices to be made just one of which is
this energy conundrum if we don't get it
from russia
where do we get it from pivoting the
european energy market and especially
the heating market away from natural gas
towards renewables represents a real
opportunity for something positive to
come out of this situation
doing so will require upfront investment
and a lot of ambition
but achieves multiple objectives reduce
greenhouse gas emissions in line with
the eu's stated objective of bringing
emissions down to 55 of 1990 levels by
the year 2030 improve air quality by not
burning natural gas modernize the
european workforce and increase energy
security bringing increased control of
energy production into european borders
reducing price instability reducing
costs to consumers this is a horrible
situation but an opportunity
alongside demanding that our governments
help alleviate the humanitarian crisis
let's also demand that they increase
support for low carbon heating in homes
and increase support for new renewable
electricity generation doing so helps
the environment sure but it also helps
the workforce and acts as a further
sanction on the russian war economy
the use of new technology is going to be
a key factor in successfully degassing
the european energy mix though keeping
up to date with all the developments in
tech is pretty difficult getting a daily
digest of the latest news in tech and
business and finance and policy for free
would be ideal wait sorry
it is
it's free
this is where morning brew comes in the
free daily newsletter delivering to your
inbox the latest news in tech business
investments policy you name it reading a
morning brew is a great way to start the
day because instead of just aimlessly
scrolling through social media in bed
you actively brief yourself on what the
world is doing right now for example you
might learn about china's position on
the ukraine conflict or about a new
startup that recycles electric vehicle
batteries it's a witty rapid-fire
roundup of everything you need to know
to meet the day if you're a person who
wants to know more about the world there
is literally no reason to not sign up
it's completely free and takes less than
15 seconds to subscribe click the link
in the description to sign up for
morning brew and make your mornings that
bit smarter with thanks to morning brew
for sponsoring this video
thank you so much for watching this
video all the way to the end if you'd
like to learn more about this topic in
the process of editing this video the
iea actually published an article that
was 10 steps that europe can take to
reduce its dependence on natural gas
i'll leave that link in the description
which goes into a little bit more detail
than this video i'm donating half of the
sponsor fee for this video to the
disaster emergency committee who are
providing support to refugees in ukraine
i'll leave a link in the description if
you would also like to support their
work i really hope that you took
something positive away from this video
you now know what demand of your
politicians if you did please do pop it
a like and share it with people you
think may also find it interesting if
you want some recommended viewing next
here's some stuff from me on youtube and
that just leaves me to say thank you
again for watching
i'll see you in the next one